hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
right now i'm standing in newport wales
outside this beautiful investment
property that was recently purchased by
my very good friend hilary how you doing
i'm great how are you very good so you
just bought this house about a month or
two back yeah yeah a month a half ago
you've ripped the kitchen out she is
literally ruthlessly pulling things out
getting this refurb not myself
not your hands having it done yeah so
what was it that made you decide to buy
this little house all the way over in
wales newport uh good price we're
working for 75 000. 75 grand yeah uh we
like the area because it's in greater
newport so we know the valuation is just
going to go up what do you mean by that
um because newport is growing as a city
so i'm gonna like down the line yeah
it's gonna go up and on this road
um an average three bed house is 125 130
grand alright for 75 so oh yeah
right however your house number one's
estate yeah number two it's not a three
vote or two bed
yeah and as now so you've got a lot of
work to do yeah so should we go level up
yeah come on then folks let's go have a
look around show us the crash oh
front reception room
right oh jeez yeah this is a state
so what's what what we got oh it's dry
rock yeah so we got dry rot here
weren't expecting it
but then when they started to
to look around and see check out the
mold and everything then they saw that
it's like
like that it's just like falling apart
yeah
nasty nasty so this stuff why is this
why is this bad you can see it's all why
is this bad why do you not want this
yeah yeah because potentially you could
spread
um if it's not fixed and it's just not a
stable stable flooring yeah and i want
to provide someone with a stable
flooring right so basically if you just
flawless and left the wooden
or all this rotten water it's just gonna
get worse it's gonna spread it's gonna
be wonky you're gonna struggle to put
the the wooden beans in to hold the
floor up yeah so you're gonna have to
get new wood put it down yeah that's an
extra expense yeah a thousand six
hundred and fifty so
one thousand six hundred fifty pounds
yeah fair enough yeah we weren't
expecting to have to do this yeah um
contingency
is it central heated yeah that's fine
yeah we just need to add another one to
the extra bedroom so visually it looks
terrible but actually
yeah it's not going to cost that much
money yeah
okay dining room
fine we're just going to cover this up
yeah
um then it's just you know painting
flooring this room's fine okay what kind
of floor are you putting on carpet or
laminate laminate flooring
nice
it looks terrible doesn't it really yeah
but it's for now it looks terrible
you know just needs new paint job and
just like flooring and then it's just
called manufacturing yeah visual stuff
so so the boiler then is the boiler all
five boiler is fine now for this
thankfully the broiler that's the thing
that you know things like the um the
electrics or the electrics fine
yeah yeah we just have to move a couple
things around upstairs
and then that's it electrics boiler fuse
box all this sort of stuff windows are
good yeah that's the kind of stuff that
costs a lot of money to fix but visually
you can't tell much difference
whereas the stuff that you've got to do
in this house like for instance put your
kitchen in how much is it going to cost
about kitchen in here like 15 102 grand
something like that 1502
but visually you now have a kitchen yeah
here's a really interesting thing
most
first-time buyers
wouldn't be able to buy this house would
they
no not necessarily because they're not
well a if they're not educated on
bringing it up
um
yeah or they don't have the money or
they're just scared because
they don't know what they're doing right
or they can't get a mortgage on it
because
it's
yeah it's not habitable but what you're
doing which is really cool
is you're buying a house of course
you've got about money and i'm looking
forward to going through the figures
with you in a minute but you're buying a
house that's run down
but you're actually helping the economy
and you'll help me by by turning a
rundown property into a beautiful home
providing that to a first-time buyer
whether you're going to go on to sell it
or if you're going to rent out so you're
actually helping the economy and um you
know helping first-time buyers which is
awesome giving your family at home
absolutely absolutely yeah so let's have
a look into the bathroom
so this used to be a full bathroom this
it was the top sink and toilet um now
we're just gonna have a washer dryer
here
and we're gonna save the toilet we just
have to obviously clean it up because
it's covered in mold yeah but
yeah that's fine saving a little bit
there and i think as well so you're
turning this from a three bed house
sorry a two bed house into a three into
a three bed and what do you think that
will do to the value of the property
when you turn it into a three bed it'll
go up a lot why is that because in this
area it's like the the margin between
two beds and three bed is really high
actually like 10 or 20 grand right okay
so let's have a look upstairs let's go
oh this is massive yeah huge room
so this is this is where we're going to
put two bedrooms instead of one right um
so we're building a corridor here to
lean off to the main bathroom yeah i'm
gonna put a tub in there fix that all up
and then the wall for the two beds is
gonna go right here so one small room
other small room
uh we just have to put another radiator
on that wall
um and then move the light because the
lights are in the middle of where the
wall is going to be yeah so bring in the
electrician to bring put a light there
in there
and that's it so instead so if you were
to sell this house once you've done it
who would be the typical kind of person
that would buy this house and what would
the value be of this house once it's
finished yeah so the value is going to
be like 130 hopefully 135 right um and
just a like a
first-time buyer family maybe an
investor who wants to just rent it out
yeah um but i would imagine a family
lives here because there's there's three
bedrooms so yeah and presumably you're
gonna have you know maybe a family
they've got a couple kids yeah exactly
two rooms for the kids small rooms but
not tiny box rooms with small rooms
family bathroom you've created the
corridor and then hopefully this this
this third room is going to be a decent
size because this will point to mom and
dad yeah it's a bit bigger yeah let's
have a look
oh really nice good
well not nice
no it's a good size yeah yeah it's good
it's not nice but it's a good size what
the heck is going on here
yeah so when we bought the house this
was all covered
um there was just kind of like a small
piece that was that look like this yes
um
and then it's just destroyed it's like
when you do that the stone is coming off
of it yeah um so we just have to cover
it in and redo the whole thing so what
they're gonna do base coat and skim it
yeah um and then and then and then paint
it another thing is this really
interesting when you bought this house i
know a lot of
um a lot of properties that we buy as
biorefurbish refinance you buy them cash
initially yeah so you bought this with
bridging finance yeah
and then once you finish the project you
then refinance it
would you be able to get a mortgage on
this property with it being stones and
things like that would you be able to
get a mortgage should you want to or is
the plan just to sell it no if i wanted
to i could get a mortgage um
i just plan look
we haven't decided yet but we're leaning
towards flipping it just so then we can
get more cash to put into a different
project i can get us more cash flow so
you bought it for 75 so here's the big
question
kitchen bathroom you having to fix the
roof up yeah you're having to get the
dryer to start with all the carpets the
paint absolutely everything including
contingency worst case scenario
how much is it going to cost you to get
it all completely ready to sell it or
ready to refinance it
yeah the refurb's going to be about 24.
24 grand yeah is that how much you
anticipated it being or no it would be
cheaper no we thought it would be about
22 and a half right but you know the
flooring downstairs in the front room we
have to do that we weren't expecting um
and then just the cost of materials have
gone up yes
so just a little bit more of it
for 75. we spent about 24 on it so all
in all you're talking about 99 grams
yeah did you basically are you able to
claim about the standard duty or is do
you have to pay stamp duty and legals
yeah stamp duty legals right yeah you
also get the bridging costs bridging
fees yeah as well so how much in total
is everything all including all of the
costs you're talking 99 for the purchase
price and refurb and then you're
probably talking about what maybe two
grand plus legals a few
bridging costs how much is that
yeah so that's gonna be an extra
probably five or ten when at the end of
the day yeah so if we flip it if we can
sell it for 130 then we should be able
to profit like 15 or 20 grand right um
which i like i'm happy with that's the
first project yeah it's good it's a
little project and you're learning from
it but here's the thing as well 15 20
grand might not sound like a lot of
money to a lot of people because a big
deal a small deal takes just as much
effort yeah but
you're completely hands off but here's
the thing the speed of this project like
how long is the entire thing taking
start to finish from getting the keys to
be able to uh put it back on the market
10 weeks 10 weeks yeah and it's like i
have a project manager and i have a good
team and like this is only the second
time i've i've had to visit the property
since the reefer yeah essentially hands
off you said yeah and then i still get
to make like 15 20 grand over and you
didn't even use most of your own money
you used bridging finance yeah for the
majority of the funds yeah so
even if you end up only making 15 grand
on it probably will be close to 20. um
in in 10 weeks it's pretty good going
yeah it's like an annual it's like an
annual salary for a lot of people it's a
nice first project
the first one's always the the hardest
one to exactly and what you'll find as
well big deals and small deals are the
exact same work yeah so if you're doing
like flats if you're buying something
and turning it into five flats it's
gonna take just as much energy doing
that as doing this but you'll make five
ten times the profit that's the thing
yeah but this is just something small
and
and easier yeah just to get my foot in
the door just to get some experience
absolutely absolutely yeah really really
well
this is really exciting yeah because
this is my first
like brr project yeah
i can tell you in your face you're just
like oh my gosh it's crazy when did you
first get into property and how did it
start
um my partner
wanted to go to your crash course so
then we went together
um what are you doing because you just
moved from canada a couple years prior
right yeah i was working in a restaurant
in canada
yeah i was well in canada i was
restaurant manager then i moved here
then i was a waitress in london
um
yeah and then we went to the crash
course went to the deal finding
extravaganza during the academy
that was
uh just under two years ago i think 2019
2018 yeah yeah yeah and now
we're doing this you're so so good and
what would you say has been your key
sort of if you if you were advising
yourself from two years ago what's the
biggest lesson that you could kind of
give yourself back in time
i'll go faster go faster really yeah
just um you know get the you know you
still have those little voices in your
head you can get all the education that
you want but if you still have a little
voice in your head you're
gonna go slow so slow what do you mean
little voices just the negative doubts
in your head yes so if you can get rid
of those
just you know just move faster because
it took me two years to to do this which
is you know it's fantastic that i'm
doing this but i could have done this
last year how long did it take you to
become financially free
um
a couple months ago okay yeah so it took
you about 18 months 20 months from the
first crash course yeah yeah to become
financially free still though that's
pretty slow but i'm sorry it's pretty
fast when i got there yeah
that's the thing as well i think
everybody compares themselves to
everybody else yeah and comparison's the
thief of joy and you feel like oh it's
so slow tell me 20 months to become
financially free and buy a house but
it's not actually
from starting as a waitress just moved
from canada just bought a property where
you're going to make about 15 20 grand
it's really really really really
impressive so
my massive hats off to you and what
you've achieved and what will be your
final words of wisdom someone watching
this that needs some inspiration or some
insight best piece of advice and go oh
just do it
just do it get those get those doubts
and the little voices out of your head
and just do it yeah the the first deal
is always the hardest so if you can get
the first deal over the line
and and you can surround yourself with
the right team then you'll just do it
amazing amazing well guys i hope you
found that useful i hope you enjoyed the
video if you did drop a nice comment
below for hillary don't forget to hit
the like button subscribe and we'll see
you guys next time
[Music]
you